[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVENPORT: At MIT,
there was always
a desire to elevate the arts.
Jerry Wiesner very
specifically would say,
you can't do good
engineering without the arts.
He really believed
that the arts were
integral to a good education.
The Film Section actually
started because of a class
that Ed Pincus ran out of
his studio in Central Square.
And so many students
at MIT signed up for it
that the powers that be decided
that they should move it
to the main campus, and find
a well known filmmaker who
could head the film section.
And that was Ricky Leacock.
LEACOCK: I was first
asked by Jerry Wiesner
to come teach Film/Video at MIT.
I was very hesitant.
He rephrased it, and
said, what do you
think that a place like
MIT could contribute
to the art of filmmaking?
And it's for this reason
that we take very seriously
the effect of technology
on the creation of movies.
DAVENPORT: Ricky
is often described
as being the father
of cinema verite.
He became a documentary
filmmaker very early in life.
I think he made his
first film at age 14.
LEACOCK: What I
love about the kind
of filming that I've
spent my life doing
is that there are
always surprises.
You always have a
preconceived idea
of what you think
is going to happen.
And it's as you see that
preconception disintegrating,
and the film becoming
something entirely different,
that you delight.
DAVENPORT: The Film
Section actually
started as an
undergraduate program.
It didn't take graduates until
three years into the program.
So we had Introduction to
Filmmaking, Intermediate
Filmmaking, and
Advanced Filmmaking,
and students flocked to it.
So in terms of its relationship
with the student body,
it was a very
happening endeavor.
Students loved the technology.
They loved to be able
to express themselves.
And they loved the adventure,
I think, of going out of MIT
to try to tell a story that
wasn't in their immediate life.
The students shared.
They shared their techniques.
There was a very
relaxed feeling.
But there was also
a driven feeling
of everyone wanting to
go out and make a film.
LEACOCK: This film, it
was a wide open program
of asking people to let us film
aspects of their private lives
that they wanted filmed.
This requires an
awful lot of energy
all the way through the term.
DAVENPORT: Ricky wanted to
make double system equipment,
so that anyone could make a
documentary film that they
were interested in making.
I came to MIT to
work on Super 8,
and I couldn't understand
why you couldn't
sync a sound recording that
you made on a tape recorder
with the film that came out
of a Super 8 film camera.
MIT had the answer.
The Film/Video section
became the venue for artists
to come to, and want to screen
their films for our audience.
The Monday night screenings
were always open to the public.
Mary Jane Doherty, who
made the funniest films
that were released.
I mean, she really had a
wonderful sense of humor.
DOHERTY: This is an experimental
astrophysics laboratory.
WEISSKOPF: Heavy double stars
that rotate around each other,
you know, and--
DOHERTY: (WHISPERING) This is
a famous theoretical physicist,
Dr. Victor Weisskopf.
WEISSKOPF: --emit
gravity waves, and this
is what Ray is looking for.
WEISS: So one of us has to
stand on the table, huh?
Or we stand on ladders.
STUDENT: Well, two
ladders, actually.
WEISS: Two ladders.
Wonderful.
Heroics.
You might as well go to
become Ringling Brothers.
STUDENT: Yes.
DAVENPORT: I think the
move to the Media Lab,
it was by choice.
But it was also
sort of self-evident
that we needed to go
there if we were going
to invent some of
the new technologies,
and the new approaches to video.
And that's of course
what MIT is all about.
It's about invention,
and moving on to the new.
In terms of Film/Video,
it was very clear
to me, and to a few
others, at the Section
at that time, that computers
were going to totally change
how we edited.
Ricky himself, I think, was
not so interested in staying
long term at MIT.
He wanted to go off and make
more of the type of movies
he'd been talking about
using the Video 8 technology,
and just see what you
would make if you hung out
on the streets of Paris.
One of the really
strong memories
I have of the Film Section,
and the Film/Video Section,
and even my groups here, the
Interactive Cinema Group,
are all the fantastic
people who went through.
It really was remarkable,
particularly in the early days.
I think there wasn't anything
like that in the country.
There are many very accomplished
filmmakers who came out
of the Film Section-- Ross
McElwee, Rob Moss, Steve Asher,
Bernice Schneider, Alex
Anthony, Mary Jane Doherty,
Barry Strongin,
and just many more,
moving through into the days
of the Media Lab as well.
Yeah, very influential.